with a piece of antiquity now in full view
after nearly two Millennia it's believed
to be the site of the most pivotal and
Infamous moment in the Roman Republic
the assassination of Julius Caesar now nearly
a century after it was Unearthed the ancient
Square known as Largo Argentina is open to
the public Chris livesay reports from Rome
it's been called the most pivotal
betrayal in the history of the world
it too brutally Then Fall marking
the end of the Roman Republic
and the beginning of an Empire shall in
these confines with a Monarch's voice
but you could never see the actual place up
close where Julius Caesar was assassinated
the sacred area of Largo Argentina until now for
the first time the city of Rome has opened it to
the public it was a crime scene yes exactly but
instead of yellow police tape it was layer upon
layer of successive civilizations keeping
it off limits says Rome cultural heritage
superintendent Claudio Parisi precise the
excavation were made between 1926 1929
but was never possible to go in at the level of
the ancient ground floor now about 20 steps below
street level takes you more than 20 centuries back
in time thanks in part to more than one million
dollars from the Rome luxury brand Bulgari the
most interesting in that one just because it has
been turned into a church Jean Kristoff boban
is the CEO so you can eventually discover the
four temples the many of The Monuments exactly the
way they were seen by the Roman citizens in 400 BC
but the Shakespearean showstopper where Senators
stabbed Caesar to death on the Ides of March 44
BC well you'd easily Overlook it Caesar's Heir
Augustus had it walled up and declared a cursed
place so that's where Caesar was assassinated
and the world was never the same yeah yeah and
we have the possibility to identify this wall
because we know from the literary sources that
this room was on the middle of two toilets and
so we discovered the toilet we know the wall is
exactly dead hold on Caesar was assassinated
by the bathrooms uh was outside the room
but was very close to this room the toilet
blaring are the ignoble Echoes of the past
but today you can also hear the purrs of the
present the cats have always been here as we
told the time of Julius Caesar so they have
only been here volunteer Monica baraski takes
me inside the feline Sanctuary that's been amid
the ruins since 1993 after the cats some Strays
others abandoned started Gathering here can I pet
him yes yes he's very very sweet Cezanne like the
painter yes here they look after and sterilize
them by the Dozen many are disabled now protected
far below were any Fiat or Vespa can hurt them
such is the Eternal City where life and history
have no choice but to co-exist you have people
walking by you see scooters buses there's a bus
stop right yes exactly yes the modern city
uh go on and and so the life is not stopped
in that moment this is The Treasure of Roman
for CBS Saturday morning Chris lives say Rome